love is in the air here on CBS this
morning do you feel it all next week
rotated to bring series we're calling
world of weddings we sent our team of
Correspondence around the globe to
explore what getting married means to
different cultures and as we find out
the celebrations can be traditional
unconventional and simply inspiring our
special series I'm Remy
innocencio in Mumbai 90% of all
marriages here in India are arranged by
moms and dads Americans might asked why
Indians would answer why not coming up
next week the biggest loudest most
colorful marriage you've probably ever
seen I'm Adriana Diaz this is my idea of
heaven I am in a bridal shop where you
can see these beautiful dresses now as
you know the big party in the white
dress have long been a tradition here in
the US but some couples have decided
that less is more especially when it
comes to planning coming up next week we
will show you how some American couples
are planning their weddings in less than
one minute
[Music]
and a celebration of love prostration
and cultural barriers as recently as the
18th in jails for getting married
I'm Seth Doane at a 400 person wedding
celebration in Tel Aviv they're taking
many of the Jewish traditions and the
guys at the centre of this are calling
it marriage but technically they had to
go to another country to get married for
Israel to recognize their union we'll
have that story as we explore the world
of weddings next week on CBS this
morning
[Music]
wow what a great series my brother and
sister better be watching because
they're both getting married next are
they yes Joshua and jasmine Duncan watch
the series married in less than a minute
yeah we're both like who in and on you
know it's I I this is a great idea yeah
the series really is our special series
continues you can see more of it
starting Monday and we'll start with
Ramey honest NCOs report of an Indian
wedding that almost looks like a movie
production it all begins Monday right
here on CBS this morning